[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice welcome to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and your money open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five among george's many
jobs in this uh locale called ramsey
solutions he is the host of the
newly uh popular big hit the fine print
podcast where he explores the fine print
that is screwing you over in various
industries
and uh george the
is it the is it the new one that just
dropped i picked it up on my walk this
weekend on um
uh christmas holiday spending holiday
spending is that brand new is that the
the newest one okay i'm look at that
look at me i'm caught up it's so great
thanks for listening by the way sure i'm
trying to trying to boost the
listenership here but the uh it that's
really that was really intriguing and
really good you guys did a great job
with that thank you i hadn't seen the
outline or the wireframes on it or
anything and so i was just having the
full user experience as if i was a
consumer student instead of the owner of
the place and um it was it's really
insightful i mean with all this
disruption with supply chain inflation
cray-cray out there i mean
you know
crack-a-doodle man the whole the whole
culture's got lost its dadgum mine and
then let's have christmas
right
we started it going okay let's do one on
black friday and what you need to know
to not overspend during the holidays and
all of a sudden this global supply chain
disaster hit and we're going oh my gosh
there's more to this story and on top of
that you've got all of the baggage that
comes with the holidays when it comes to
family and expectations and boundaries
and so we had dr john delony come on
there to talk about not only how to curb
over spending but how to deal with
family and how to say no and how to set
up healthy boundaries that are
respectful to family and you get a lump
of coal and you get a lump of coal and
you too that adds to the stress of the
holidays yeah so i mean
i couldn't i did i hadn't really
half paid attention because my need for
stuff is fairly low
uh but 28 billion dollars worth of goods
sitting in la harbor long beach harbor
alone on 73 ships or something yeah you
nailed it i mean that's that's real good
i know that's pretty close to that your
memory there pretty close to that
because i was just like
that's a lot of money floating
out there and they can't get it off yeah
that was when we shot it shot or when
you when we did the recording or the
recording but might they may have gotten
some of them offloaded now but yeah it's
still just and then oh might be a little
back up with the old truck drivers after
that oh my goodness basically everything
is bottlenecked and it's making
everything expensive it's hard to get
which means you've got a plan early
you've got a budget better if you need a
budget more and that with all the
expectations with family that can turn
into a disaster and you have a lot of
regret come january we pulled a ton of
our stuff out of overseas production
ramsey products and things we've got a
few things that come but we used to
regularly buy those cartons
and you know a whole carton full of
shipping financial piece university kits
back when they we had kits you know we'd
have a whole carton coming on a slow
boat from china thing coming over and uh
it was like very inexpensive and it went
it's like 22 000 a carton now
in september it was ten thousand dollars
a carton and in june it was three
thousand dollars a card it has uh
quadrupled i think no more than that i
mean quadrupled it was nuts i couldn't
wow yeah that'll add to the cost of the
goods inside the carton hello yeah
because uh these businesses are not
eating this stuff you you people are
it's gonna consume if old barbie is a
float on the seas oh barbie's cost just
went up considering her value her value
just went through the roof that's
amazing is american girl dog
doll maybe dogs are they made in america
i don't know i don't know but it's it's
getting wild out there we're seeing
goldman sachs backwards if they weren't
but but they might not be so getting
into port is three times slower and it's
astronomically more expensive yeah so
it's causing all sorts of issues and so
i mean i uh santa claus has got his work
cut out for him the old boy's gonna have
to get a lot of that magic there's a
shortage of batteries tvs gaming
consoles laptops cell phones cordless
vacuums i mean pretty much everything
you could want this christmas that was a
pretty good joke line too if you can't
get a cordless vacuum you just can't get
it
you can't get one who's getting quoted
vacuums in 2021 i'm not getting a vacuum
i wouldn't know but
um i was going to have
rachel come over and do it but
it might be a long wait
uh i'd be hard-pressed to make it you're
thinking that's probably not the one not
the one of my children to have to do
that
no she's got her own problems
so bottom line is what do they do for
christmas and they need to listen to the
fine print podcast
but yeah get ready for christmas this
year is going to be particularly
strenuous the big takeaway here is
you've got to shop early you've got to
be looking for the deals because there's
not many of them out there to find
because the retailers aren't that
desperate and there's not that much to
get rid of and so you're going to have
to really do your research and really
ratchet down that every dollar budget
when it comes to holiday spending and
get it done as early as possible
and i heard something else in there that
i liked even better
uh anytime you're buying anything and
you get married to a particular thingy
you are about to get messed over in the
negotiation you need lots of options yes
and so an a b a c even a d
a fallback option uh default option in
case uh a and b are not available and c
is triple what it should be because of
the shortages and no other apparent
reason
then uh you need to be you know
listen the way you survive crazy is you
don't join crazy
right you got to have options well we we
joked about it being like that movie
jingle all the way with arnold
schwarzenegger and sinbad when they're
fighting over the final toy and that's
what it's gonna be like this holiday
season when you want the certain model
and you need that specific item and it's
hard to find and it's already stressful
going to the mall
you know i'm not sure how that movie
didn't end up a christmas classic it is
to me in my heart in your heart okay
you're the right age group okay which we
found out this is the most fascinating
part in the whole podcast the research
showed that there are over 200 hallmark
christmas movies
wow as of this season well and none of
them made the sinbad level no funniest
sinbad line ever has nothing to do with
christmas my dad used to put me in
timeout he'd take time out of his day to
whip my butt
oh that's good great that's what held up
great that one stuck with me yeah oh
timeout yeah
i love that so christmas you need a plan
you need alternates you need to shop
early and often and you take your time
and slow down if you think you're going
to stroll in there on the 23rd or the
24th gentlemen
to do your classic guy shopping you're
gonna find nothing in there nothing out
there may not even be toilet paper on
the shelves at that point and uh
scarcity marketing it's a real thing so
pay attention to the marketing and what
they're telling you and what's happening
to your brain limited time limited
quantity they jack up your brain and
it's real now yeah everything's limited
so be careful out there we probably have
a have a marketing uh mention coming up
that says something about ramsey
something being scarce just coming up
right after we did that i'm sure that's
usually the way that stuff falls but um
but we don't tell you something scarce
around here unless it truly is i think
we've got plenty of everything this year
from ramsay stuff books and we prepare
wallets and everything except christy
wright's uh
the calendar the calendar that
man that thing that's gonna we are gonna
run out of those and we're not gonna be
able to get more because of the stuff
we're talking about so you wanna get one
of those you best get on it there you go
folks there it is check it out the fine
print podcast all kinds of wonderful
information there every week in this
week featuring how to shop for christmas
properly george campbell my host co-host
this hour this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
common sense for your dollars and cents
and a culture where common sense is so
rare that having it is like having a
superpower andrew is in atlanta hi
andrew how are you
well gentlemen pleasure to speak with
you you too what's up um
so i have a quote i was just recently
informed by the all-knowing government
that my student loans are being
transferred to navient
and
given the questionable nature of that
company i'm wondering if that changes my
debt snowball the student loans are
nineteen thousand dollars
they're currently fourth in line in my
debt snowball
and uh i estimate being fully debt free
in uh the spring of 2023.
okay what's in front of it
uh two credit cards
and a land contract
which i also wonder if the land contract
carries more risk given something you
said recently yeah yeah um so the land
contracts almost paid out
it's not much older it'll it'll actually
it yeah it actually is probably number
two
yeah um it's actually hard for me to get
my head around not doing so what is the
what is number
the student loans are number four what
is number three
number three would be a credit card yeah
what's the balance what's the balance
11 000. okay and what's your household
income
110
okay all right
so the stuff after the student loan is
what's dragging you out into 23 not
before
correct because you're going to be
busted you've got to be busting through
these four making 110 fast right george
yeah yeah i mean as far as navigating
i'm making some changes yeah naviance
sucks but they all do yeah i don't think
you have any worries there i wouldn't
adjust the snowball because of that no
um especially with your income
you i'd get these credit cards out of
them i was just concerned
is just one we featured in borrowed
future but they all suck
and you know what it'll probably be
transferred again before you pay him off
and so that's just the nature of that
industry so i wouldn't be worried about
them screwing you over i mean it doesn't
whoever it's sitting with in the student
loan world is they're not as much
crooked as they are just incompetent
which is actually worse because crooked
you can actually catch incompetence you
can't fix
and so you just have to manage you have
to watch your account and make sure
they're posting stuff the way they're
supposed to all the time anyway
whoever it is so just watch it like a
hawk and keep it right there's what i
would do yeah i don't see any need to to
move it around in the debt snowball i
think you just stay the course and use
this income to your advantage and maybe
try to increase it if you can to speed
this thing up because we're talking
you're done with the student loan though
and
what six months
yeah i'm probably done with it and um
by the end of 22. i've got a whole
spreadsheet that tracks yeah i think
that's a little late i think you need to
turn your snowball up a little bit
because not 30 000 is the last two i
don't know what the first two are but
making 110 you need to get there i mean
yeah you need to get there inside of six
months yeah i don't want to keep these
things around like a pet but but that
that's that's a different subject but no
i wouldn't move it to answer your
question i would watch them like a hawk
but any of you that have a student loan
you need to watch them all like a hawk
because they just can't find their butt
with both hands i mean they really are
incompetent they're just not i mean and
don't care
and they don't care they just do what i
mean they just lie yeah with every
payment i'm going to be checking the
website making sure they took out
exactly what needed to be taken out and
no more and watching that thing
constantly auditing your own account
yeah that's what you've got to do with
these people oh the navient people were
just it's just a
michael's in houston texas hey michael
how are you
i'm doing just fine thanks so much for
uh taking my call guys sure what's up
i got two things for you um number one i
wanted to at least provide a testimonial
for some of the advice that you're
giving on here my wife turned me on to
your show about four years ago and um in
four years
we are completely debt-free
we've paid our house off
36.
thank you and um our net worth now is
about 1.2 million
wow
so way to go baby steps millionaire i'm
proud of you
thank you thank you it took a lot of
work it took a lot of sacrifices but uh
yeah we are completely in the green
touchdown man incredible way to go hero
thank you
thank you so what this kind of leads me
to um it's kind of a two-part question
number one
as far as our retirement goes we have
about 730 000
at this point um with an investment
company and that's already been invested
and our next goal is that we're still
living in the house that we bought
together it was our first house
and um we're just starting to feel a
little bit cramped so we're looking for
an upgrade good so while i'm saving up
enough money for the house and let's say
that i need to save up about another
um hundred and fifty to two hundred
thousand dollars my question for you is
this should i feel
as i'm saving up that much money because
it's a lot should i feel the pressure to
continue putting that towards my 730 000
in retirement and then the other
question is that if this is going to
take me about two to three years i'm a
little bit unsure in how to invest it
and i know that you can't call the stock
market i know that you can't time it
but my biggest fear is that i invested
in something and then you're two or
three years from now
um i have less than what i put into it
yeah so uh
the 750 000 is in retirement accounts
right
yes like if you take it out you get a
penalty right
yes so you can't put it in that if you
want to use it to buy a house
no no the uh the idea was that i wanted
to take that money and start to invest
it somewhere else and then open up like
a secondary are you saying you're gonna
stop contributing to that retirement
account to save up for this house
that was kind of my question is that
while i'm saving up for the house should
i continue to still be putting money in
my retirement accounts or do i have your
blessing
to say you're in a really good place
right now um you should put it towards
the house you're a millionaire you don't
need our blessing for anything
but we would tell you as a matter of
course just to continue to put 15 aside
and above that save for your upgrade
that shouldn't make or break your
upgrade to lose out on that 15
exactly that you're investing so i would
yeah on anything above that 15
i would be putting away and if it's two
to three years that i don't i wouldn't
be putting it in mutual funds that's a
little bit short of a time horizon
um but when we saved up for our house if
it's three to five years we worked with
smartvestor pro we invested that and it
grew
it grew a little bit which really helped
us with our down payment situation so
one to three years is a little bit
tricky on the market
so here's the here's the here's your
here's your probability so you can split
it up do some of each if you want uh in
terms of uh whether you put it in money
market or whether you put in mutual
funds if you leave a mutual fund a
general market mutual fund good growth
stock mutual funds across the four types
we talk about alone for five years 96 of
the time it will make money
if you leave it alone three years 67
percent of the time it'll make money one
out of three times it'll lose money
okay but it won't lose a lot
i mean it might lose it might lose you
know you might put in a hundred thousand
dollars it might be worth 95 you know or
something so it's not like you're gonna
lose all your house money but you
probably won't you won't make any money
that's appreciable and so that's why i
said you might play the market on some
of it and some of it you might not play
the market but even by playing the
market in air quotes i'm going to be in
some very conservative mutual funds and
money markets or i'm going to be all in
money markets if i just don't want to
worry about it at all
but if i really want to take a little
bit of risk you might lose a few
thousand dollars if you're only leaving
it alone three years yeah and with a
high yield savings account i mean you're
looking at a half percent so it's not
the sexiest thing but it is guaranteed
and so you have that um as far versus
losing money in the market in a short
period of time exactly and the way i
look at it is you know a typical mutual
fund
year in and year out averages 10 to 12
okay a decent decent track record mutual
fund all right and so
it's got to do really sucky to get all
the way down to a half a percent yeah
and so i i personally am willing to play
that but but i don't want you to lose a
little bit of money and then go oh
i lost all my house money you didn't
lose like you instead of having a
hundred thousand you got 95. you know
but you might have had 120 you know too
that's the other side of that that's
your spread of risk it's not all or
nothing this is not a roulette wheel
so you're not playing you know you're
not playing bitcoin you're not playing
beanie babies and you're not playing
gold here this is a a low risk scenario
so your range of risk
is really small
really small so either way you go but if
you're going to get down under three
years i start to get nervous and i just
start to park it in money markets
if i'm in your situation that's what i
would do
so good question thank you for joining
us this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jim and jenna are with
us hey guys how are you hi how are you
welcome welcome i love your tie-dyed
b-weird t-shirts
best t-shirts of the week that's
impressive very colorful i needed some
color here that's uh we're ready to go
man
i was born in the 70s when i was born in
the 60s but yeah but oh my gosh still oh
that's incredible so uh where do you
guys live
uh we live in perrysburg ohio just
outside of toledo western part of the
state welcome to nashville and how much
debt have you paid off
731 000
that is sufficiently weird
and how long did this take a little over
nine years all right and your range of
income uh we started at 125 000 it went
up and down in between there even a year
of unemployment for me um and we ended
at just short of 130 so not much change
between start and end cool what do y'all
do for a living
so um i work at bowling green state
university go falcons um jim and i met
there no college of education there and
our oldest two also attend there so um
i gotta love that tuition waiver uh
there so
i work in stem education
um teach some and also work with
teachers in in our area
wow
home of my uh hometown of my good friend
scott hamilton yes oh yes yeah and a
famous runner from the 70s you know what
his name was
uh dave waddell oh yeah okay
i went to ice hockey camp there when i
was 12. nice on that sheet of ice
i doubt it's still there it's probably
melted down literally yeah but um wow
same building though
i bet it is wow very cool yeah southern
boy goes to the north and get my butt
kicked by those northern boys playing
hockey but that's what happened but very
very cool learned a lot learned a lot
well welcome guys okay i'm guessing i'm
going to surmise nine years 731 000 and
be weird t-shirts means you're paid off
your house we have paid off our house
that is correct yeah yeah you are
officially we're done we are done bunch
of weirdos yeah i love it
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you what's the house worth uh 250
000. wait a minute
yeah it's very cool yeah well tell us
about your ramsey journey that started
nine years ago what happened uh well the
journey started a lot longer than that i
would say shortly after we were married
um i was introduced by my newly acquired
father-in-law to this guy by the name of
dave ramsey
and he was trying to give me all the
acquired father-in-law he was giving me
all sorts of advice and i did what any
other you know young 20 something year
old thinks that they know it all
um completely paid no attention to what
he was saying and went about our lives
and sure did what every newly married
couple does buy new cars run stuff up on
credit cards
um thought we were living life what
we're supposed to be and then in the
early 2000s we bought some rental real
estate and that's where a lot of our
debt came in and attempted a point we
owned five rental properties all
completely 100 leverage done exactly how
you weren't supposed to do it sure and
the time we thought we were creating
future wealth and in reality what we
created was a financial disaster and
when 2008 9 and 10 came and the housing
crisis took
all of our rental properties down to
you know nothing we struggled finding
tenants we struggled getting people to
lease
the values of them dropped significantly
and
we were at the end and that was into
2012
13 where
we were
two days away from filing bankruptcy wow
and about ready to throw in the towel
completely
and um trying not to lose it very good
just couldn't do it couldn't let my kids
down and we were two days away we had
the chapter 7 bankruptcy petition all
filled out ready to go and they said
we're just not going to do this we're
going to fight our way out so
my full-time job or our full-time job
over the next couple years became
dealing with all the banks brokers
short sales avoiding foreclosures
and
made our way out from that and sold them
all took a significant hit and
refinanced
we did stupid things like you always say
not to do we borrowed money from our
parents so when we bought the properties
or borrowed money from both sets of
parents to use towards the rental
properties that we were buying
your father-in-law who tried to get you
to do dave ramsey he loaned you money
nothing down real estate
so i might be really good at selling
people i'm getting people to believe
what i believe so wow
um yeah like the wrong person converted
the wrong person well it's funny well so
he he passed away nine years ago and
that was part of it in 2012 when i saw
what he left he was a guy that
drove the 1996 jeep cherokee his whole
life and i and i started to pick up on
that when he passed i realized the
legacy that he had left for his wife and
now his daughter and son
and that was one of the eye-opening
moments for me when i got to see behind
the curtains like now i now i understand
why you did what you did and that
changed my life so he was an everyday
millionaire he was an everyday
millionaire that you would never know it
he was the guy that drove the old car
lived well below us means and you just
didn't know it and now we do
and so after we refinanced all of that
debt back into one big snowball that's
been the last six years um that we've
thrown everything we had at it and
including our house
we had a car loan in there um loans to
the parents
um
and it it it was significant there was a
lot of dark moments but um so you guys
narrowly avoid bankruptcy father-in-law
passes away and you guys go never again
never leave a different legacy for our
family that's exactly right i looked at
our kids and they were probably our
biggest cheerleaders without it and
without without any hesitation they were
our biggest cheerleaders and they didn't
know it because we just couldn't let
them down
i refused to let them down and we
weren't going to quit and we were going
to make our way out of it and it uh and
for a long time this story i wanted to
keep to myself i was embarrassed by it i
didn't want anybody else to know and
then just in the last year or so i'm
thinking maybe there's somebody else out
there that is going through the same
things maybe some people have done the
same stupid things we did and we can
provide hope because there was a lot of
dark moments and you're looking at
little kids and are all of our kids dave
they grew up with the financial peace
junior envelopes i mean for 15 years
they were little kids running around
with the yellow envelopes and the velcro
thing putting their money into it and
saving it
and
and now i'm so proud of what they've
done and they understand what we've gone
through now and they've been a big part
of this journey so we also had fun on
the long road trips in the car
um
we uh you know when uh you could turn on
the hot spot or the wi-fi we wouldn't
turn it on until we listened to a couple
dave ramsey episodes and made them
listen and then tell us what they
learned so uh oh yeah angled it like a
carrot yes yes you were a four-letter
word many times our youngest could sing
your opening theme song since i think he
was about 10 years old
they weren't really happy when we went
on car rides a lot of times because they
knew we had to listen to you in fact my
future son-in-law is out here with us as
well today and the first time i really
got to spend time with him wait a minute
you turned into that father-in-law
that's exactly right so this is exactly
this is full circle it is you're going
to love yourself that guy right so four
years ago
after the shortly after they started
dating i went to pick him up from school
and it was a three hour trip back to
toledo and i made him listen to three
hours of your
show because i wanted to make sure that
this dude knew what he was getting into
and i am proud to say he's wearing one
of the t-shirts he's wearing one of the
t-shirts he just bought his first car
for cash and my daughter is proudly
wearing a debt-free diamond there we go
married
he is he is he's a keeper we've decided
we're going to keep him
i'm uh i'm taking high odds on the over
and under that big jim will be crying
walking that one down the aisle because
big jim's a crier like me 100 that's
exactly right without question yeah
changing the legacy literally in front
of our eyes yeah i didn't say i mean i
wake up every day inspired to educate
mentor and influence kids so together we
can change the world and
we have generations of kids graduating
from high school having no idea what
they're doing completely lost having no
idea how to find success thinking that
living beyond your means is the norm
having no understanding of personal
financial management and i'm i'm blessed
to lead an organization that
believes we can create a world that kids
will graduate from high school with a
clear vision of future success cool let
me get you guys in to the shot before we
do the debt free stream i'm about to run
out of time here come on so the name of
the kids are brooklyn jimmy trevor and
the son-in-law is lance
all right guys everybody's here with the
shirts this is awesome what a great
story you guys you've been through hell
and you made uh you made a lot of good
stuff out of all that manure i'm proud
of you very well done jim and jenna and
the gang from toledo ohio 731 000 paid
off in nine years making 125 to 130.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Music]
well done you guys very very very well
done we appreciate you being with us
what a great family
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
feels like it's too soon to start
talking about christmas
i know thanksgiving's still a couple
weeks away but here's the deal we know
and george talked about it on fine print
this week that the earlier you get
started for christmas with all the
disruptions out there this year
the less likely you already mess up your
christmas budget
so a big reason for that uh we're going
ahead and get started because we're
going to give away some cash
the ramsey cash giveaway every every
year we celebrate with our ramsey show
listeners with our ramsey christmas cash
giveaway it's become a tradition this
year we're giving away 500 every week
and we've already started
and a grand prize of 5 000 bucks so
given that you're glad we started
christmas early right there you go so no
purchase necessary got to be 18 of
course go to ramseysolutions.com to
enter
and you can go ahead and get into in on
the giving too we've got all kinds of
life-changing gifts for you and your
family our famous 10 sale on our
best-selling books that means you can
shop over 40 of these bestsellers and
envelopes for 10 each or less uh you can
get books like number one bestseller or
total money makeover uh christy wright's
2020 gold planner also is a great gift
they are selling out fast that's one
that is actually
uh scarce so don't forget the one time
use pres or do forget the one-time use
presence and uh give a gift of lifetime
of hope give away some total money
makeover books and some rachel cruz's
books and christy wright's books king
coleman's book so on ten
dollars each at ramsey solutions
open phones this hour
this is the ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five florey is in cleveland ohio hi
flori how are you
hi i'm good thank you for taking my call
um i apologize i'm like super nervous um
no problem we never lost a patient
i love that line uh my question is i
guess i'm like all over the place with
my uh finances
and i just kind of need to know where i
should be um
make a long story short um
i i'm a hairdresser i worked for a
one of the top like
salons in cleveland ohio on the west
side
i ended up leaving that position the
owner
during the pandemic actually ended up
died by suicide so
and then
yeah so kind of going through a lot um
the new owners ended up basically i'm
kind of making
different changes
a lot of the stuff that
i was taught and i was there for almost
10 years i've known him since i was like
14. um
big mentor
you know and i learned a lot and i'm
grateful for that but
things changed so i went off on my own i
and then i
started
booth renting
um
and i was on a non-compete for a year
and then now i'm back in the city that i
used to work in
running my own studio
with full salons i don't know if you're
familiar with that too much but
i rent like a space and i basically run
my own business
so my question is
i'm trying to shop around for health
care
i know i should have that but i am 33
years old i haven't really
had the need to have it um
my financial advisor my cpa is all
telling me like get yourself health care
and
so my question is
do i
basically
not pay extra on my house or do i take
that from like my
contributing to my like
uh my boss ira because right now i'm
putting 500 a week excuse me a month in
my wrath
i have no doubt besides yeah okay george
so i'm just trying to like budget and i
don't know what my budget is
i'm still trying to figure that out so
you don't have health care right now at
all
correct okay yeah that's going to be
your a1 i mean you can jump on
ramseysolutions.com we have insurance
pros in cleveland that can help you
navigate this help find the right option
and that's going to become a budget line
item and anything on top of that if you
you don't have kids
no kids single yeah okay so if you've
got no debt that fully funded emergency
fund you're investing 15 of your income
into retirement then you're going to
start paying off that house but it's
going to be only after you've budgeted
for all the things that are a part of
your life like health care so any money
left over you can put it on on the house
but yes that's going to cut into the
money that you would have put on the
house hey florey
yes today
get on the dad get on ramsay solutions
get one of the health insurance elps do
this today
you want to know why it's so important
here's why it's so important the number
one cause of personal bankruptcy in
america today
is not credit cards it's not student
loans it's not overspending it's a
medical event with no stinking health
insurance
yes
so my other question is
you kept driving too fast girl
raise your right hand dave i will go get
health insurance today
dave i will go get health insurance
right away today and you're saying um
instead of like that money that i was
like putting towards instead of like
paying up because right now i'm paying
more on my mortgage
you can't pay extra on your mortgage
until you've met your budget
and your budget now includes health
insurance because you raise your
right-handed stuff
yes
so how do i budget and like what should
be my expenses
versus my profit like for a small
business
so you're talking we got to split the
personal on the business side are you
running these out of two different bank
accounts
so i have an llc um but i'm basically
paying myself from my business yes
okay because your book your budget for
your personal life and your budget for
your business are going to be two
separate things so we've got to make
sure that we've got those separated in
different accounts and
when it comes to expenses versus profits
dave can speak to what that's going to
look like as a business owner but on
your personal side you've got to get
that piece down first and make sure that
you are paying yourself a living wage
yeah it's fairly simple you're running a
single chair operation
your income is you have very little
expenses you have the cost of the chair
and you have some supplies
and so your income comes in you pay the
cost you pay your expenses for operating
the business everything else is profit
and you're probably bringing all that
home
and that's fine you do need to set aside
a fourth of that for your taxes you need
to be withholding on yourself because
you're an independent subcontractor and
you need to be filing a uh you need to
be following your quarterly estimates
once a quarter on that and again your
financial advisor cpa can probably hook
you up with a good bookkeeper to do that
or check tax pro tax elps at
ramseysolutionsquad.com
while you're there looking at the health
insurance
pros
so flori um
what i hear is somebody who's had a lot
of
emotional trauma
through the pandemic
with the non-compete the loss of the job
the loss of your friend the owner
that mentored you the new people coming
in jerking you around
um
your story had some pain in it
and i understand that and i'm with you
on that
the trick when you go through pain
is to come out of it very
process and systems driven
john deloney always says facts are your
friends
and in talking to you you're just kind
of circling the airport all the time
that's why i hit you so hard to make you
land the plane on the health insurance
you also need to land the plane on your
taxes land the plane on your budget you
need to get very sis very systematic and
don't be circling the airport anymore
land
on some of these things and get very
precise it's very easy in the pain
because the pain was as much of your
story as the details were and i
understand that i'm not against that
i've been there myself i know how it
feels
so um
you know but make yourself the way this
thing the way the the all the
uncertainty and the pain will go away is
by putting these detailed processes in
place yeah and i want to do one more
thing for you florida kelly's going to
pick up and i'm going to gift you one
year of ramsay plus that membership is
going to give you access to every dollar
which is going to be our budgeting tool
that can help you put this stuff into
place that you can look at it like dave
said fax your friends and go oh what are
my expenses what is my income and you
can go watch financial peace university
there's a great lesson on insurance in
there that's going to tell you exactly
what you need and more importantly what
you don't need there's a lot of crappy
tools out there crappy insurances so go
jump on that watch the videos get
plugged into every dollar and you're
going to have a lot of confidence moving
forward and kiddo you made me a promise
better follow through
today
you need to go get health insurance
doesn't affect me at all but it's going
to affect you
you need to go get health insurance
right now like you promised
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life your
money george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print host of entre
leadership and co-host of this show
today is my co-host so check it out
george campbell and i'll be here talking
to you about your life and your money
it's common sense for your
dollars and cents the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five tyler is with us in
springfield missouri hey tyler how are
you
better than i deserve how about you dave
just the same sir what's up
well i have looked forward to this phone
call for a very long time
but at the age of 24 me and my wife are
officially in baby step seven wow
that stinking impressive hero way to go
it it it doesn't seem real i'm not gonna
lie what's the house worth
uh roughly 275. gee man how did you do
that at 24.
i sacrificed a lot of time away from
friends and family to uh work a pretty
well paying job oh cool what do you do
i'm a truck driver okay so you've been
like 80 hours a week huh
oh well oh my god that's not legal
that's not legal it wouldn't be that
many wow
a lot with a partner yeah yeah yes
uh so i was calling since we are
officially in baby step seven
uh
am i crazy for
uh leaving my current job where i make
roughly 110 000 a year
to go work in the same field
and take a pretty substantial pay cut
but
be home every day of the week working 40
hours a week
what's the cut
uh i would be going
to like seventy thousand a year
okay so a forty thousand dollar putt cut
on 110
yes
okay
well because you guys are in baby step
seven it gives you options and one of
the reasons we tell people to live and
give like no one else
is so later they can live and give like
no one else and so what i love about
your situation is you can afford to take
the pay cut and it won't severely impact
your financial life can you guys live
off of your income
absolutely yeah does she work outside
the home
she does what's she make
uh about 35 000 a year okay if you have
105 000 household income you can live on
that easy got no house payment no
nothing
no trouble okay so that step is not a is
not the end of the world
okay
and yes you probably should or could do
that without you if you got babies
no babies yet okay not enough time for
it i haven't been home enough okay yeah
all right well the uh uh
yes i would do that now i got to give
you a huge caveat though
okay
because there's this uh
it is it has to be a temporary
trade-off
you're only 24 years old i don't want
you 34 driving local making
70.
yup so i want to know what the next step
is
i don't want to know today but i mean
rhetorically
i want i want to know what you're going
to do that's going to make you when
you're 34 150.
so what career are you going to move
into
are you going to move into owning trucks
are you going to
i don't know but i'm not gonna take you
at 24 and that be the end of your career
growth
yeah and you call that okay because of
baby step seven we're just gonna kick
back and take it easy no no no no you're
only freaking 24.
okay so let's go do something with our
life now and use this step back as okay
i can take some classes at night get
certifications in x y or z
i can do this or that on the weekend and
get set up to move to the next level and
start running a ken coleman program on
your life where you move into a career
that is really not only fulfilling i
mean his new book from paycheck to
purpose i'll send you a copy of it
but purpose and time with family does
not always need to equate to less money
it can on the short term
but it doesn't have to in the long term
okay
yeah so yes but not forever
yes but not for long
is the answer to your question yes i
would do that so i'll give you an
example okay out in 1990
or no
1994. i made a hundred i was coming out
of the bankruptcy and i was doing real
estate deals again and i made 120 000 a
year
in 1994. i remember this specifically i
had written the book financial piece and
i was selling them out of the trunk of
my car for twelve dollars you got to
sell a lot of those to get 100 grand
okay it's not a lot of money and i was
doing some speaking and i was making
like 250 bucks a pop doing speaking i
mean i was
not making and i started doing some
coaching and i was making 150 for doing
coaching and i was on the radio and it
paid nothing i was doing it for fun and
to feed the coaching that wasn't paying
much and the book sales that weren't
paying much but the financial piece
materials obviously grew into everything
we know today is ramsey solutions right
and so i had this call
and this pull on my life so is it okay
if i move from 120 000 a year in real
estate to move to the call that god has
on my life
and the first year we budgeted out we
knew what we were going to make we're
going to make 60 000. so i went from 120
to 60
and then sharon's walking around going
the financial piece is where but um
but the next year we made 100 and never
looked back and i obviously make a good
deal more than that now
so
the point being that that was not a
permanent thing
um
and it was but it was a decision to take
a step back so that we could take
different steps forward and we had that
ability because like you at that point
we were debt-free
um and so i could say i can step away
plus i knew i could step back into real
estate if everything got real bad
and get my income right back up so you
could go back on the road if you get
yourself in a pinch
but we don't we don't want that to be
our plan i just want you to have a
long-term career path that we take a
step back in order to take 17 forward
yeah and if you love driving trucks
that's what you want to do that's great
but have a plan for growth long term and
if you don't love driving trucks this is
a great time to sit back and go what do
i want to do like dave said follow the
ken coleman path read that book and
figure out long term he's 24. he's got
the rest of his life he's just getting
started in his career and he's a stud
yeah whatever you do you're going to
crush it because you've got an
incredible work ethic yeah and just
really focus and and detail well done
very very well done hang on i'll have
kelly pick up we'll send you a copy of
ken's new best seller
from paycheck to purpose it just came
out last week and um it talks about this
but the thing i want to push back on for
our audience george and i do this every
time ken's on the air i wear it out
because it drives me nuts this
assumption that in order for your work
to have meaning you have to make less
this assumption that in order to have a
more balanced life and have time with
your family that you have to make less
so you either have the horrible toxic
job that pays a lot and you work too
much and you never see your family or we
have this sweet little job that has
meaning and family but we make no money
how about c
none of the above not a not b c the cool
job that all has meaning and i make more
money than either one of them that's the
one you want i like that option but why
do we have to assume that in order to
have a better life that somehow we have
to take less there's this thing out
there floating around that
needs to be destroyed that's the myth
it's killing me so from paycheck to
purpose with a bigger paycheck
that's the book
this is the ramsey it's a great subtitle
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 dollars about two years
after that i got a remote job that pays
me a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
well we're coming into the time of year
where money stress
can really pile up
there's the list of christmas presents
to buy the extra travel expenses the
bills the payments and the extra food
what if money was something you never
had to worry about again
not at christmas or any other time
you know it's actually possible you just
need a plan that works
and that's what you get when you go
through financial peace university
you'll get the plan that has helped
millions of people
save for emergencies get out of debt
become wealthy be outrageously generous
get the budgeting app the premium
version of every dollar all of this is
happens when you're a ramsey plus member
this is what you need to do when you're
not always worried about money you get
to live the life you really want so this
christmas give yourself a gift that will
actually help you get there faster
start a free trial of ramsay plus
at ramsey solutions dot com slash ramsay
plus
just jump on ramsey solutions get to
ramsey plus get your free trial going
and that'll get you into financial peace
university that'll get you into every
dollar
and you can get ready for christmas
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free give free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get your
best possible deal today's question
comes from scott in vermont i know your
company teaches to never use credit
cards but i'm having a hard time letting
go of mine the rewards that i earn are
very beneficial to my family because we
love to travel my wife and i put all our
utilities groceries and other expenses
on our card and pay it off every month
what's the problem with doing this if we
never pay any interest on the card
this is an age-old question dave how
many times have you answered this one uh
six or eight thousand um the uh uh but
the thing is you just did a great
episode on uh the fine print about this
yes we did one on credit card rewards uh
and
the numbers are worse than i remembered
yeah the true cost of credit card
rewards is what that episode was called
and we talked to an ex-capital one um
lady named elena and she really unpacked
the secrets that they're using to take
your money and a lot of people think
well i'm not paying any interest so
what's the big deal dave yeah i'm not
paying any more than i would have if i
paid on it with a debit card well
obviously that's not true
okay you're not paying any interest but
here's the here's what we know the step
from the studies
uh carnegie mellon did a detailed study
and uh
using mri
and they actually determined that when
you use cash it activates the pain
centers of the brain
when you use plastic
nothing happens no brain but um
but the uh but i mean it's just left
flatline right and so what it might do
is you emotionally experience buying
something and have a tendency to spend
less when you spend cash visualize
everybody listening right now 100 bill
in your hand leaving your hand oh god
right uh and and visualize you hand
here's an interesting thing too rachel
cruz brought up years ago
when you hand them the hundred dollar
bill
they don't give you
it back
when you hand them your plastic
they give it back
think about when you were a kid or
something and you were trading
you know you traded something
or when you give some you give up
something to get something that's what
you do when you pay for something with
money but when you give them your card
they give it back you didn't lose
anything see how that feels
psychologically so it doesn't activate
the pain centers of the brain plus cash
just does and so here's what all the
studies tell us depending on the area
and the item you're shopping for you
will spend 12 to 18 more when using
plastic
than you will when using cash
when using a debt that's when using a
credit card when using a debit card
you'll even spend more i use a debit
card but you'll spend more i'll give you
another example okay
uh
george are you old enough to remember
walking inside the store to pay for your
gasoline oh yeah okay before you paid at
the pump
okay
let me tell you what happened
the last time people had to walk inside
and pay for gasoline and it doubled in
price
there was almost a revolution
they were going to burn washington dc
down
now it goes from 250 to five dollars and
nobody notices
because you just pick it you just plug
it in the thing pay you for your gas and
walk away the only thing you notice is
you didn't didn't seem like i got that
much gas well that's weird okay and you
drive off but if you walk into the store
the physical act of walking into the
store and pay cash and that registers
that freaking gas is doubled i'm gonna
kill somebody you know you you start to
have this experience
and so that again shows us that there's
a behavior mechanism going on you can
take it one step further move away from
plastic used to apple pay or amazon
prime where there's no friction at all
i mean you don't have you're not even
touching something physically you're
just waving your you know you go to home
depot and you wave your little
phone across and you just bought like a
house of lumber you know but you just
waved your phone you didn't even but you
didn't emotionally experience it no i
just bought tools i don't even know what
they do but i just waved my little phone
across i do it with my apple watch oh
yeah it's even worse
here's what i do dave you're gonna love
this starbucks drive-through line you
got the watch and you just hand it over
like a tiny king and they kiss your
wrist
as they scan it
[Laughter]
that's why people go to feel like
royalty
well i have noticed that with the dunkin
donuts app that i buy more donuts too
but that's how it works it's the same
thing because you don't you don't have
to pay for it it's already paid for it's
built in chick-fil-a you can eat like
half the dead gum restaurant and not
even know you bought it so
the point being guys everybody falls for
this stuff i teach it and i catch myself
falling for it that's why disney let's
your room key
if you're staying on property work to
buy things all through disney smart that
way they can charge you 82 dollars for a
ring coat they paid 12 and a half cents
for from china because disney causes it
to rain every afternoon on cue
but um you know it's built right into
the system nine dollar ice cream cone
right
and but your room key did it and you
don't even think anything about it it's
the happiest place on earth
and then you go to check out and you're
like oh my god i got to refinance the
house you know it's like so this is
what's going on so that that's the
problem with his little theory yeah is
he thinks he's the exception to all that
because he got some airline miles here's
the other thing
78 of the airline miles are never
redeemed
that that's 8 out of 10. that's sad
that's everybody okay so if you do try
to redeem them jupiter has to be aligned
with mars to get on the plane i mean you
have to get the age of aquarius to get
everything to work there's all kinds of
restrictions on those points exactly and
that they do points on purpose if it was
actual money you'd know but with points
you go i got 48 000 points yeah that's
amazing i'm wealthy and your point in
the year that was a fabulous metaphor
you used in
the fine print episode oh it's like
going to chuck e cheese you know you you
spend 83 dollars getting all these
tickets to trade it for a 12 and a half
cent plastic ring you know but i got me
a lot of tickets what's your cash back
and it's all free by the way it's all
free because it came with a pizza you
know
i tell people to give yourself cash back
save up for your own vacation that's
what you can do when you're debt-free
and you make a plan for your money i
don't have to hope at the end of the
year that we have enough points to take
our family on a trip you know we stayed
10 000
plus millionaires
and um
90 percent of them 89 of them were first
generation rich started with nothing
and
out of all 10 000 millioners we
interviewed not a single one said made
all my money with my airline miles
they didn't say that wow they didn't say
you know i gained the system i scammed
all capital one because me i'm smarter
than old capital one i mean i'm smarter
than i'm i'm they they spent more on
that one commercial that ran one time
that i made in a year but i'm smarter
than them
the arrogance of this is unbelievable so
the fact that you think that you're
whipping their butt scott is kind of
humorous
i'm sorry son you're not whipping their
butt they're whipping yours this is how
they built buildings taller than your
house
you would love to just trade the
furniture in their lobby for your home
you know but no you've paid for every
bit of it and i know you think you
didn't fall for it but you spent more
and the number of times during your life
you fall off the wagon don't pay it on
time and accidentally slip into interest
because
a high percentage of credit card users
eventually pay
some interest yeah um and everyone
thinks they're the exception
a little bit like a fishing story
you know like golfing story that one
time when i hit the ball just right you
know that one time i caught that big
fish and you spent seven million dollars
trying to get to the point you got that
one fish
you know and it's just like it's the
same crap yeah so dude follow what
millionaires do not what broke people
with theories do
and that's what people playing credit
card points are they're broke people
with theories if that makes some of you
mad out there
good
that's my spiritual gift
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brad and julie are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave
welcome where do you guys live uh we're
just outside of atlanta georgia and
cartersville yeah welcome to nashville
thank you so much and all the way up
here to do a debt-free screen how much
have you paid off six hundred and
seventy six thousand nine hundred ninety
seven dollars and thirty nine cents
how long did this take five years good
for you and your range of income during
that time uh started off at 75 and ended
at about 175 wow what do you guys do for
a living well well so
uh
currently i just ended my uh 28 year
career with one of the country's longest
family owned and operated wineries in
california
so i just finished my consulting with
them and i'm going to reinvent myself
and julie i am starting my own small
business i
create unique handbags all right that's
fun good for you guys thank you yes so
you were living in atlanta consulting
napa
uh not napa the livermore valley oh okay
yeah but yeah so i was a director of
operations so i was passing torch to the
the person who took over my position
yeah plus helping out on some uh it type
of thing so very cool good for you so
677 over five years you pay off your
house yes
two times
the california house and then uh the
cartersville house wow yes wow
do you still own the california house no
no we did not sold it okay we sold it
and uh we we came out
very well i can suspect that yeah very
well done you guys okay so what happened
to put you on this journey five years
ago well um in december of 2015
a week before christmas my dad passed
away
and then the very next day i found out i
was losing my job oh my gosh so it was a
dark time yes it was it was a really
dark time for me
and you know i was freaking out um
you know i realized you know sitting
down and doing the bills we're a
thousand bucks short every month
thousand bucks you know too many bills
you know i mean yeah car payments 401k
loan a heloc this i mean a bed i mean
just if we had a if we had the checklist
of stupid from you dave
we ticked every box and added a few okay
yeah because uh you know under
miscellaneous yeah miscellaneous which
is refi
roll the car loan into the refund oh yes
30 years start over 30 years yes um
kick the can kick the can but you know
and and at that point in life
didn't even realize there's a can didn't
care right yeah you're young enough um
i'll work my way through this you can
make the payments yeah no biggie we're
still eating right until you can't until
you can't and then you're a thousand
bucks short then what'd you do well then
it was you know we realized like oh my
goodness you know it's just us you know
we didn't get anything from my dad's
estate you know this is us no one to go
to for help i mean
i'm a huge talk radio guy so
um
i couldn't tell you how many times i was
driving home from work hearing you on
the radio and then listening to two
minutes
and going to the next channel because
it's like uh what's this get rich quick
guy you know there's no way
until i was in that position and um
that's why we got to thank you dave i
mean you you literally saved our life
and i'm hoping that we can touch
somebody with a similar story as ours
because
i eventually stopped and i listened and
when i got home that night i said we got
to check this guy out
he came home and he was like julie i
heard a guy on the radio
and i'm like
okay and he's like yeah i really think
we should get out of debt
okay mr amazon
i'm the free spirit i'm the free spirit
she's the nerd i'm prepared
and so yeah so
that was in february so
2016 and then we signed up for fpu yep
and i got to give a shout out to um kim
and garrett
um our coordinators they're awesome we
still talk
and um yeah we just went gazelle from
there um it was actually funny because i
was like i have no job i'm you know i'm
sitting in these fpu classes i'm like
steve i'm not going to be able to pay
this off you know
but
you know once we started going through
the classes and working the snowball
whatever we could you know throw at it
it's like oh wow i think this is
possible and and i must say you know
anybody out there that's thinking about
fpu or yeah what is it and
if you have an opportunity to do it and
we've gifted it before
do it
you're gonna feel weird the first two
weeks undoubtedly you're going to feel
like
julie said what am i doing here what am
i doing but you meet a lot and i i
encourage you to go to the actual class
you can do it online or you know through
dvds but go to the class meet other
people realize you're not the only ones
with these problems yeah and actually i
hate to say it but i felt better we felt
better coming out of the class by the
third week because we realized we had a
lot of debt but we were nowhere near
some of the other folks in the room but
uh the other thing is and this goes very
very true for single folks
you probably feel the worst because you
feel like you have nobody out there but
you know folks like us you can all
relate you all have death and that's
what's happening right now in this
country we got a huge problem what's
going on with the
you know with the healthcare situation
right now and all that
now is the most critical time for folks
to shut the cards off get down get your
feet dirty yeah and hammer it out
because it can be done it's not going to
be fun it's not like oh this is awesome
you know i'm not you know
who doesn't like to go get a five dollar
coffee in here like royalty you know
yeah just my watch
so brad and julie i'm just i'm looking
at the numbers and i'm just like in awe
how did you guys pay off 677 in five
years making what you make
sell some stuff what happened yeah well
yeah in a second yes okay so so our
biggest one was our california house
that was like 188 000.
and so we paid that off um
in september of 2020
and
we're like cool and then we're like
let's move
and so then we decided we were
originally looking at tennessee we
settled on georgia and so we were like
debt-free for three months
and then we bought the georgia house
and moved across the country in january
um of 2021 and
sold the california house and then paid
off the georgia house okay and had
a nice chunk of change left over and
yeah getting back but prior in
california before we you know actually
paid that house off oh yeah it was
everything it was comic books musical
instruments
sold my motorcycle and what was cool was
the dude that i sold my motorcycle to i
gave him a screaming deal um he he came
out the night before looked at the bike
came back the next morning with cash and
uh
he came into our house and i think you
have some of the photos there we had a
mortgage chain
going down our hallway wow
so this guy's filling out we're filling
out the paperwork and i'm like you know
and i see his face i go you're wondering
about the
the links on the wall he's all yeah
what's what's up with that
so we told him dave ramsey goes oh i
know i know about dave ramsey i go yeah
you're helping us pay our debt off right
now
that's awesome and i go you know for me
i i love selling my motorcycle to a guy
who appreciates it he actually brought
his high school friend from nor from
southern california up to northern
california and they were gonna go on a
bike trip and it was like you know what
everything happens for a reason it all
works out yep so now you're 100 debt
free and oh you can buy a bike anytime
you want exactly yeah so what's your
first big thing you're going to do now
that you're out of debt
you know quit your job apparently yeah
we already did that but yeah yeah we did
that you know but i mean
i've never been happier i mean our
i think that's the thing dave it's like
what what's going to be your big thing
at um i know you're looking at things
differently right yeah
uh well dude we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story to move on and be baby
steps millionaires you're right on your
way to do that and we just got ken
coleman's new book just in the mail a
couple days ago so that's actually
perfect perfect timing for the job thing
excellent
all right well let's count it down brad
and julie currently of atlanta georgia
677 000 paid off in five years making
75-175 count it down let's hear a
debt-free screen three two one
[Applause]
that dude's about to run through a wall
hopefully not this glass this is triple
payne he's not getting through it but
man what an inspiring couple wow they're
on fire way to go heroes proud of you
guys very very well done
that's how you live life man get after
it get it get it
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today kaziah is with us in
minneapolis hi kaziah how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm getting married in february
and um i am
living in an apartment right now with a
couple of friends but i'm looking for an
apartment to move into before i get
married so then i won't be as hectic
during the wedding
and there's just not a lot of apartments
available in my area
and i don't have a credit score
which is totally fine
but um i also me and my fiance both just
got new jobs recently so we also don't
have any like proof of income to show
the apartments so we don't exactly know
how to go about that
when did you get the jobs um like three
weeks ago
and they're looking for like multiple
months and i had jobs before of course
but they're looking for someone that i'm
like currently employed with
i think you've talked to apartments
we did an interesting thing we did an
experimenter here a while back
we called all the major apartment
complexes in the nashville area like 30
of them
two of them required a credit score
oh yeah i i i'm totally i called them
and they're totally fine with me not
having a credit score i agree with that
um but they just need a proof of income
which i have an income i know so just
get a letter from your employer i'm
gainfully employed i just started a new
job i'm getting married i mean how many
pay stubs do they need yeah she said
like they want multiple years or
something for a freaking apartment
that's silly no you
i mean
you're not a freelancer right this is a
salaried position
um i have a like a lot of my income is
from babysitting and then from an
internship and then from a preschool so
i have multiple streams of income but my
main one might so you don't have a pay
stub except from the preschool yeah
except for the preschool yeah
so that that's your problem yeah yeah i
think you need to look around and find a
landlord find an apartment who's willing
to look at all the sources of income and
say hey this is clearly something that
you can afford and recently on the fine
print we did this day and we called all
around the country we called normal
single-family homes with landlords we
called apartment complexes and all of
them just said hey you might need a
little more deposit so you're just gonna
need to explain your situation like a
human and they should be willing to work
with you if you find the right place
yeah occasionally you'll run into
somebody who's just being a corporate
geek and is following the barney fife
letter of the law or something but but
most of the time you can say okay look
here i can show you the budget i can
show you exactly what's going on to show
you i've got these six jobs babysitting
and they're i'm a legitimate nanny this
is what i do it's just independent
subcontract and i've got this this stuff
pay stub and your fiance if uh if he's
signing on it as well if he has a
traditional pay stub that'll be enough
as well
but um yeah you're going to run into uh
some people that aren't going to
understand without a cr without a credit
score and you're going to run into some
people that don't understand without uh
a traditional job
but um but you just have to search a
little bit more that's why i was
challenging the number of times you've
done this and the other thing is this
quit emailing people and texting them
go sit down and look at them in the face
and that'll change the that'll change
your outcome as well
go sit down like you seem like a very
reasonable person i'm sure you present
well sitting in front of someone and say
here's the story here's the situation
i'm getting married here's the guy i'm
getting married to and would you all
consider it in this situation no
no
no
yes
you know that's what you're going to get
you're going to get a few no's and
you're going to get a yes and you you
can find someone to do this but it is
going to take more than just everybody
does your deal because everybody doesn't
do any deal yeah and if you go there and
you get a tour and you sit down face to
face i think it is a different situation
than a cold email
definitely but you guys just jumped on
the phone now you were doing a credit
score only you weren't trying to we
asked them about the whole situation
they said well you need to we need to
have proof of income
and we need to make sure you're not a
criminal that was it and other than that
they said you might need a higher
deposit which you'll get back if you
don't trash the place and that was it
and with with her income being multiple
streams and some of them being
self-employed like babysitting and so
forth she may have to put down a higher
deposit yeah in that situation because
the proof of income is what she's
running into but still um
you know i
i've got a bunch of rental property and
we would rent to you but you're gonna
have to make the case
it's not gonna be just automatic like
you know well i'll make some money
babysitting let's not no no you got to
show me what's going on i got to know
you can pay the freaking rent and then
our i you're not talking to me anyway
but our property management team that's
what they would do
bob's with us in atlanta hey bob welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hey george how you doing great
man what's up
so i need a new car pretty badly i've
been driving a 500 car for the last five
years
and it's getting to the point where
everything's starting to go on and it's
got 280 some thousand miles on it you do
need i've been shopping around almost
every day and i'm having trouble finding
a used car that
seems like a good deal a lot of these
cars are
seem like double what they should be
so i went out over the weekend and
looked at a new car and i know you say
that you have to be a millionaire to buy
a new car but i just don't see the
benefit right now in saving 10 grand to
get a used car that's got you know 80 90
000 miles on it no warranty
so i don't know i don't know if right
now the situation warrants bending your
rules i just want to get your opinion on
that
well where are you at financially do you
have any debt
zero so i'm and babies have seven and
i've probably got
a net worth of like 600 and uh why are
you driving a 500 car
well it was it was a hand-me-down for my
mom i know but leave it in the side yard
and plant something in it oh my god 500
you got 600 000
dude go buy a car have you saved up for
this car already
yeah i could i'm not there yet i
probably like a month away from having
cash board i looked at like a 40 dollar
jeep what's your sixty thousand what's
your six hundred thousand in
uh
half of it is my house a quarter of it's
in a roth ira and another
quarter of it's between brokerage and
savings so you have the money in there
to go write a check and buy a car go buy
a 10 15 000 car and this crap that all
10 000 cars are worn out or 15 000 cars
are worn out dude you've been driving a
500 car
this is exponentially a better vehicle
than what you've been driving
okay you don't have to buy new there's
no i mean but you're saying he's saying
well it's not a deal right now because
of the car there's nothing that's a deal
right now new cars aren't a deal a lot
of new cars are going for over sticker
for the first time in my lifetime and
i'm 61 years old we've always been able
to buy cars on new cars under sticker
and some of them are sticker plus a lot
of them are sticker plus right now
because there's a shortage on them and
that's what's driving the used car
market bonkers as well is there's a
shortage so i would just go get me some
kind of car my god get out of a 500 car
and then you're going to move out of
move again out of the car it's not that
big a thing it's not that big a deal so
i was looking at a
uh
an escalade the other day and the brand
new escalades are bonkers people have
gone it's an upgrade they've got this
like 36 inch screen in them they're nuts
and uh the guy at the dealership's a
friend of mine he goes yeah i'll give it
to you for sticker and i'm like i'm
buying nothing for sticker
and he goes dude if you go up the street
to the other cadillac dealer their 20
000 oversticker because you can't get
these wow and i'm like
unbelievable so i got neither that's
what that's the move right that was a
different move but yeah it worked i mean
i'm not mad at him it's just not the
time for me to buy a car obviously now
suit but dude you've got to fight but a
lot of people are in that boat they're
going with 500 cars a new car is going
to be way better but if you get a 5 000
car it's 10x what you're driving i mean
my god it's just you know anything is an
upgrade yeah a bicycle might be an
upgrade at this point so move up a
little
get something reasonable pay cash
here's the thing don't talk yourself
into stupid because of the markets going
stupid
you know just because everybody else has
gone nuts doesn't mean you have to
and you can justify well because of
supply chain i was forced no you weren't
you weren't forced to do nothing
you're forced to do anything you may
overpay for that used car but not nearly
as much as you will that new car and
it's going to go down in value faster
and uh those new jeeps are sweet though
40 000.
that's what that's what did him in he
went he made the mistake of going to
look at a brand new jeep and you smell
that leather and they are they're
good-looking cars man they look great
i'm a car nut but um but he'll be a
millionaire in no time he'll get that
jeep
yeah yeah not worried about it yeah and
why do we say be a millionaire before
you buy a new car well because
depreciation is going to crush that
thing like a bug and a millionaire can
take the hit
tada his name is george ken ladies and
gentlemen and he has all the answers you
could need
good stuff that's how it works
good hour good hour george well done
james and kelly in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host this is the ramsey show
and we'll be back with you before you
know
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five matt's
with us in indianapolis hey matt welcome
to the ramsey show
thank you guys god bless you for
everything you do we really appreciate
it well thank you what's up
got a question i had a 24-year career at
a previous player
and i had a
company
sponsored i guess you'd say pension plan
and when i left there i was given
three amounts
what the life annuity might be worth
at 55 62 and 65.
and i
was wondering if there's any way to try
to convert that
what it might be as a lump sum payment
is there any kind of calculator or
estimate
um because that was not given to me at
all
okay so you got the possibility of a
monthly payment for life
yes you got the possibility of a lump
sum at 55
did they give you a lump sum today
no
i'll although i have the i have the
numbers for what they will they
will they
well
probably not i would have to call the
the
company that actually handles the money
which is uh like one america and whether
they would talk to me or not i don't
know well i guess my question is is that
an option to take a lump sum today
not today
i'm 53 so we're just trying to do some
planning okay so 55
55 is the soonest
yes sir okay all right all right here's
what you're going to want to do
you're going to take it at 55.
but i'll back in and help you with the
answer to your question as well what
you're looking for is a discounted cash
flow analysis or a net present value
of the money okay and so uh when you
back that out and you run the
calculations with a financial calculator
you're going to find this annuity paying
in the five to seven percent range
okay that's what you're going to find
okay and so were you to take the lump
sum at 55 and roll it into an ira with
no taxes involved because this is
pre-tax i assume right
it's a pension yeah so it's dependent
yeah so you'll get taxed on it if you
pulled it out we're not gonna pull it
out we're gonna roll it to an ira that
way there's zero taxes on it
all right now when you do that if you
rolled it into a good growth series of
good growth stock mutual funds you'd
make 10 to 12
and you're going to find that produces
much more income
than the annuity would produce
now the annuity for life is probably
calculated out with you dying uh 78
years old maybe 80 depending on which
actuarial tables they're using and
that's how they run the numbers out uh
and so
but here's the here's the hook to the
whole thing that the deal breaker
when you die with the pension regardless
of which option you take
your estate will get precisely zero
yes
when you die with having rolled this
over to an ira
100 of money will be in your estate
yeah that's
that's the right way i definitely want
to go yeah so that not only are you
beating 12 or 10 over 7
but you're also beating zero over at
death zero over so you're better off
alive better off dead to take it but
it's okay to run the calculation out and
a smart vester pro can help you do that
and sit down it's not something it's a
little too cumbersome to do on the radio
but i could do it i could take my
financial calculator out of the
drawer over here and do it for you but
but it's a it's a series of numbers and
you have you need to sit down with
somebody take about five minutes to do
it and you can figure out then what the
actual interest rate is that they're
paying based on the different numbers
that they're giving you there's a
formula to put the stream in and you can
make an assumption of 80 or assumption
of 78 and there's a formula for putting
the lump sum in there's a formula you
said there's another number at 65. when
you put those three numbers in they're
all going to cough out five to seven
percent probably six and a half
something like that that's what you're
going to find that's because pensions
are regulated very strictly and they
really are not going to ever produce
much more than that for that reason yeah
it's interesting just doing the math on
that and saying hey if i took this out
into the ira let it grow it could do a
whole lot better than taking those
payments or waiting any longer well and
you you can turn around take the
payments 59 and a half you can't take
them at 55.
um but um but the pension
is one of the reasons that almost all
mainstream companies have done away with
pensions they're almost all gone
everybody's pretty much 401k now don't
you still do find pensions and unions in
huge companies and certainly in
government you find them everywhere in
those situations but
i mean most traditional
corporations in america today don't have
a pension anymore because it's just not
a good deal and it's cumbersome it's
crud to manage it from the employer's
standpoint it's a disaster it's really
hard
but um the uh but but so the big thing
is just when you die you get nothing and
versus when you die you get something
your your airs get stuck that alone is
good reason to take it and invest it as
soon as possible you know you talk you
know it's a hundred thousand bucks fifty
thousand bucks two hundred thousand
bucks whatever it is it just evaporates
you know and so that that pretty much
destroys the math even if the numbers
were reversed
if you only made seven
moving it and you would have got 12
leaving it you still got to think about
zero at death and it starts to offset
the numbers so you know you just still
got to do the critical thinking on it
but it's okay to do the math and it
sounds like he wants to
so sit down with the smartvista pro they
can pull out a financial calculator and
just a few minutes back into those
numbers i could do it but i'm not gonna
do it on there i used to do that on the
air and it drives me nuts because i get
two adds punch one number wrong i'm
trying to talk and then i hit it in and
it just doesn't work so
all right
so generally folks if you have a pension
lump sum option take it
and roll it to an ira in good growth
stock mutual funds with your smartvestor
pro because when you die it doesn't
evaporate that way that's your general
answer now there may be some weird
exception somewhere so it's always good
to think about it always good to learn
about it uh but in general that's some
fairly simple reasoning that'll get you
to that answer ryan is with us in
johnson city tennessee hey ryan what's
up
ryan george it's great to talk to you
guys you too sir
um
i've got a uh i don't know a serious
life question a quick backstory dave i
dropped out of school when i was 17
years old and i've worked
my hand in off the last
eight years to get to where i am today
um
but you're 25 my father-in-law
yes sir okay
um i've been a heavy-duty diesel
mechanic ever since i actually run
a shop now um
and uh
for a major company um
and
my father-in-law has approached me to
take over his construction business now
i'm not
i also own a
home
investment company where we buy fix and
resell houses
i'm currently working on two houses all
this is done with cash no bald money um
and i just i don't know i've worked
really hard to get to this point i'm
nervous
i don't i don't know what kind of
decision you know what kind of you know
i understand i guess you could say
that's a very very good question i'm
bumping up on a commercial break here so
we're gonna go make a little money so we
can stay on there and uh we'll come back
here and be sure we answer your question
a little more thoroughly i don't wanna
do it in 10 seconds so hang on ryan be
back with you this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health sharing ministry chm
has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're talking with ryan in
johnson city tennessee started out as 17
years old as a diesel mechanic now he
runs the shop doing really well his
father-in-law comes by the way he's
doing some uh fixes and flips on some
houses father-in-law comes along and
says he owns a construction company and
uh ryan we want you to come over here
and run it and that's about how far we
got in the discussion is that a fair
summary of what you told me so far sir
yes sir mate that's accurate okay cool
so what is the uh what's what's your
what are you going to do
that's i don't know that's kind of kind
of what you know wanting some advice
from you guys today uh
you know
start off you know he what it is is he's
looking to in the next five to six years
he's looking to
to pass it on and be you know
he's ready to retire he's he's worked
he's worked this business for 30 plus
years um
the last five or ten years he's just
he's got older in his age and he's not
been as engaged as he used to be but i
mean he does painting and trim work and
you know really high-end houses it's not
you know
regular mom-and-pop type houses so it's
it's specif it's specific work and it's
highly you know it's in high demand for
the type of work that he does um
and he just
is he physically is he physically still
doing the work or he has people working
for him but does it
um he goes to the job site yeah he he he
has multiple people where he's got a
paint crew and a carpenter crew but
they're doing specific type of like
trailers
paint work yeah they're doing craftsman
they're doing high-end stuff it's not
slap it on there but he's not swinging a
hammer or a paintbrush anymore
he still goes to job sites but you know
he works the farm he'll you know he may
go job site and help guys if they need
help but he he's not required to be
there like you know
like he used to be you know years ago
building the business and this and that
he don't
he's got he actually let the business
get a little smaller than it used to be
he used to have about 60 or 70 employees
and now he's he's around
he's in the 20s
but like i said last five or ten years
he hadn't really wanted to work
okay so what's the profit on the
business
um
i don't know
it's okay we haven't sat down and talked
those numbers but basically he can
he can replace my income as and you know
as far as what i'm making here
today i'm putting in long term you're
doing this to get your income up
yes yes okay so i don't want to know
what that is i mean replace my income
what do you make now
um i make between just depends on how
hard i you know want to work between 85
and 90.
uh you know depending now i'm still an
hourly foreman so i run you know i still
run a shot but you know if i want to
work extra every time i can get you know
i can get into the high 90s just depends
on how how hard how much i want to work
that's that's just from my current job
that don't count my you know the company
that i've got where we buy and sell
houses uh i think i made like between
foreman and that last year i made like
135-ish or something
what are the what are the terms of you
taking over the business
basically uh he wants me to get in there
and learn this hand trade
i would be at par i would be
an owner from day one basically
um so you know he's always just he would
go work the job sites and he would get
to pay for pay for you know the what he
would earn that week that's all he'd pay
himself and the rest of the money that
all the other carpenters would work and
that he would make on top of what him be
on the job site he would just put in the
business account and then he would pay
himself
you know quarterly or once a year just a
bonus or something and
i mean he's he's got a very high net
worth uh well over
three million dollars so he's done so is
he gonna get he's gonna give you this
business at the end of the story
at the end of the story end of the day
he wants me to run he wants me he's at
this business he won't know you running
it for him is different than him giving
it to you which is it
it's it's
he it's you know he's gonna give it to
me at the end of the day but he just
wants me to learn the trade i understand
running
i said at the end of the story so you're
25 when you're 30 this will be yours
yes but yes okay now when you're 50 what
do you want to be doing with your life
diesel mechanic
or running high-end trade
uh i'm gonna work for myself dave um
uh you know that's not the answer and
you work for yourself doing anything
yeah that's true you could be a diesel
mechanic for yourself and not run a
shopper yourself uh you could be a
high-end trade for yourself what do you
want to be doing every morning when you
get up monday morning you're going to
work have a smile on your face like i
did this morning
yes sir i've been doing this 30 years
and i still like it
at the end of the day dave i could be
doing either one of these jobs and be
happy at the end of the day um bull crap
i'm limited i'm
i'm i love them both now listen you you
you are good with your hands and you are
such
a freaking hard worker
that you are you are content with
anything that is hard work that you can
make a living and i want you to rise up
above that and get into your head not
just your hands and go
what's going to make me smile when this
is big
and you don't have to answer me but you
got to answer you before you make this
decision
i think you're going to go to work for
him and the hand that take this over but
i want you to be really sure that you're
not just doing it just because it's
there
because you'll be miserable don't be
miserable
and look back and go i live my
father-in-law's dream
yes sir ryan's dream
that's what we're after here and it's
okay to do that i mean my kids are
involved in this business they're taking
it over they're not going to be
miserable we've gone through a very
detailed process to make sure it's god's
call on their life for them to be here
or don't be here because nothing's worse
than family business when somebody don't
want to be there
yes sir i i tell you what dave i i won't
do anything it makes me miserable i'm
i'm yeah i want to come home and you
know be with my family and enjoy the
time i'm with my family so i want and so
they really enjoy what you do
you aren't doing those real estate deals
just for money you enjoy that project
based
get stuff done take something and
transform it and put it back out in the
marketplace looking better than it did
and make some money on it you enjoy that
don't you
you're a absolutely who fixes things so
i think you're going to end up doing
this but i want you to get down inside
your heart talk with your wife and then
the other thing is with your
father-in-law don't assume squat this
needs to all be written down
yes sir that's that's what that's one
thing he said he said we can get with
his his order yeah like on this date if
i am competent and i have learned the
trade you will turn it over to me
yes sir that needs to be in writing okay
so hang on i'm gonna have kelly pick up
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose will be helpful to you but more
importantly kelly give him this career
assessment
that we've got now and it is ryan it's
just magical it'll take you about 15
minutes to take it and you will have
insights into yourself you can go over
it with your answers with your spouse
you and your wife look it over you could
even go over it with your father-in-law
it sounds like he's a great guy and just
talk it through and go what does this
the answers to this assessment
lead me to this deal
yeah that's a very interesting situation
where he can do anything and he's a
hard-working guy but what does he love
to do because that's what i'm looking at
is you could take over the business and
go all right this is fun but when you
have options which he does right now i
don't want him to feel obligated to step
into family business and then step into
a nightmare down the road exactly and
it's um
both of these jobs are activating the
same stuff inside of him that makes him
you know he does stuff with his hands
he's a fixer he's gotta fix his stuff
so that and that's all perfect for both
of these that's one of the reasons he's
saying that but i want him to push past
that
and uh
ken's this this new book that is it is
really incredible yeah uh to get really
clear on what it is you're going to do
that's step stage one of these seven
stages to get to move from paycheck to
that get clear assessment that you're
talking about that purpose statement
that it gives you is so it gives you
such clarity and you go up want to run
it through this filter nope the trade's
not going to do it yep i need to be a
diesel mechanic i need to be in real
estate yep and i um yeah
and
you do move through the process i talked
about this with ken's group the other
night when we did that live stream for
his book you do move from the process of
just having a job
to make a living and feed your kids eat
keep the lights on and then you move to
career
and then the best of the best is when
you get to move from career to calling
when you move into your calling
that's where the joy is that's where
their soul deep work in your work yeah
and you and i are both experiencing that
personally yeah so good stuff this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt free stage in
the lobby of ramsey solutions james and
emily are with us hey guys how are you
hello hey we're good welcome welcome
where do you guys live uh we're in
kennesaw georgia just north of atlanta
awesome welcome to nashville good to
have you second atlanta debt free
screamer today very good how much debt
have you guys paid off uh just over 50
000. awesome and how long did that take
you 17 months good for you and your
range of income during that time uh
sixty thousand to seventy four thousand
very cool good for you what do you guys
do for a living
so i um now am a stay-at-home mom
because we had a baby during that time
and i
work part-time at a treatment center to
help um substance abuse clients okay and
that was your career before it was yeah
i was full-time um i i just kind of took
a step back to take care of our baby
absolutely cool and what about you james
what do you do i run a lawn care
business in the kennesaw area awesome
very cool what kind of debt was your 50
000
my student loans
it was my student loans my car
was a good bit of it and then a credit
card too yeah no mowing equipment no
he runs a debt-free business because of
you i love it that's awesome
there's pictures of that too by the way
yeah i see them they're showing up here
on youtube very clean it mows better
when it's definitely that's that's some
kind of pickup you got there the humble
beginnings that's the beginnings of the
whole process check it out okay he's got
a real truck now he's pulled it with a
honda accord before
it's good i love it well done dude i
like it that's cool and so uh debt-free
dude marries
emily nguyen how long have y'all been
married
just over a year it was august
2020 we got married okay so before you
even got married you started on this
idea of getting out of debt and then
completed it after marriage and then had
a baby yep he uh been busy he uh
was the initiator of the whole situation
i can imagine yeah how did that go down
tell us that story so i had proposed to
her uh early and i guess it was 2019
and it was kind of a time where
i
i didn't really have a plan or goals
with money i didn't have like i was just
you know flying through the wind with
everything and you know i came across
your stuff from our friends
and to have like a straightforward
direct like follow these instructions
things was was super easy for me to get
behind and i really liked that a lot so
you know we discussed it together that
this is kind of what we wanted to do for
our life and how we wanted to live our
life and to grow and to prosper
and then uh so we set the goal and then
you know we found out we were pregnant
with lily
not long after we got married and so
uh that kind of
made things real and made things sort of
like yeah it kind of gave the timeline
like i was really i personally was sort
of pushy with it i was like i really
want to try to get this done before she
comes
um if we can so that we can come home
and not have to worry about that
um so but we did we as soon as she was
born in home safe and healthy as well as
me
um we paid it all off you got the money
saved and you chunked it in that's
perfect that's exactly what you're
supposed to do um during that time
though we were able to cash flow our
wedding um pay for an acl surgery for
one of our dogs
and to pay cash for her birth oh wow
yeah and he's building this lawn care
business with cash the whole time yeah
yeah he was doing that um and i worked
three jobs up until um i gave birth wow
man you guys have been after it for 17
months so what was the heart of
sacrifice along the way that you guys
had to make
uh
i don't know sacrifice i was really i
really like eating out um but i would
say the hardest part was probably when
we came to the grips we you know we we
did financial peace as kind of our
pre-marital thing
um we we went through the course online
at the time because it was covered um
but we when it when i when i had to
personally accept that our bank accounts
were going to be joined that was very
difficult because i couldn't do what i
wanted to do with my money anymore it
was like you know i had a built-in
accountability partner and it was kind
of that was the most difficult part to
me i think wow so along the journey you
guys had to combine finances and you
were going i don't know how much i like
this but now you see the benefits of it
when you get on the same page absolutely
yeah oh yeah how's it feel now to be
free
i mean that financial piece is the
perfect way to describe it you know it's
like it's kind of i feel normal like
this is kind of it's hard to describe
like i felt weighed down before and
stressed out a lot and you know i'm sort
of a naturally high anxiety person as it
is
and so to not have to worry about that
is just huge i mean it's huge it really
is just like
that sigh of relief like it's like this
part's taken care of you know like we're
okay and we have a goal and a plan now
that we have a direction that we're
going in financially and like i really
you know want to do that for our
daughter and for our family and our
kids kids so
you guys are heroes you're so fun you
changed everything for her
i mean she's she's got a great future
because of you two
because of the way you've taken control
of your life congratulations i'm so
proud of you thank you thank you yeah
it's it was tough um i'm a spender i
would say um
and it was difficult but i think having
him was super important because at times
i wanted to be weak he was strong and at
times he wanted to be weak like i was
strong and i was like this is why we're
doing it like we need to remember that
and
i took out a ton of student loans not
knowing what it was going to do and now
my daughter is never going to do that
amen
amen well done yeah that's that's the
family tree that's changed right there
it's not the 50 000. it's what happened
in both your hearts and in your marriage
and everything else during that time and
that's worth uh five or ten million
uh that's what it'll result in as young
as you guys are how old are you two
um i'm 27. i'll be 35 in december okay
very cool good for you guys yeah the
future is bright baby future's bright
very very very well done and what's your
baby's name
um her name's lillian lillian okay and
she's visiting off to the side i
understand she is yeah she might freak
out she's a little camera shy at her age
okay that's cool no troubles no troubles
oh good all good well done you guys who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
i would say our friends were kind of
cheering us on along the way a lot of
them uh they didn't necessarily friends
and family were cheering a song along
the way they didn't necessarily buy into
what we were doing
uh because it's you know not a normal
thing
in the eyes of society but they they
cheered us on yeah yeah like everyone
wanted you're weird but i love you yeah
yeah yeah
you guys are doing good yeah that's good
i like it well you never know some of
them may come along now that you're
having this sense of peace that they
don't have yeah yeah you know so good
stuff so what would you guys say to the
couple out there who's about to combine
the finances they're getting married
they've got a pile of debt and they're a
little bit anxious about all this stuff
um
i would say i mean
you said it really well george when you
said that like it kind of it gets us on
the same page because otherwise even if
we both have the same goal but aren't
combined in what we're doing it's just
still off a little it's like not you're
not really there you're not walking hand
in hand on the same path you're kind of
walking two separate paths in a similar
direction and it's like just so much
stronger it's like getting in the car
and driving down the highway rather than
wandering you know it's like so much
better for me it was trust
like i took that extra leap to trusting
him because i told him straight up
i was like i kind of want a separate
savings account just in case like what
if um and
his exact words where you're setting us
up for failure and for divorce
and um
yeah
i'm fighting words
that was pretty cool that was before
being married um so we still got married
but he was he was right like
i don't need an escape route because
we're in this together like we're in
this together and
beautiful beautifully that's strong
i don't need an escape route because
we're in it together that's that right
there's tweetable i'll take it back back
when people that were real were on
twitter but yeah oh my gosh way to go
guys so proud of you got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that is the next
chapter in your story for sure that's
where you're going next and on the baby
steps millionaires before you know it
and i can't wait to hear from you when
that part of your story occurs as well
really well done copy the total money
makeover for you to give away for one of
those doubter friends and maybe you'll
bring them along on the journey all
right it's james and emily and lillian
from marietta georgia 50 000 paid off in
17 months making 60 to 74. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
count one two three we're different
that is how you do it ladies and
gentlemen
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today james 1 12 blessed
is the one who perseveres under trial
because having stood the test
that person will receive the crown of
life that the lord has promised
to those who love him
joe vitale said a goal should scare you
a little
and excite you a lot
that's the truth so let me ask you a
question when you think of a millionaire
what kind of job do you picture them
having
some kind of high-powered executive
position ceo vp
well here's the thing only 15 of a mil
of millionaires actually have jobs like
that the reality is the top five careers
for millionaires in america are engineer
accountant
teacher
manager and attorney
and that's just one of the surprising
things our team found when we conducted
the largest study of millionaires ever
done
they talked to 10 000 millionaires about
who they are and how they achieved that
goal our study also made it clear that
to become a millionaire you've got to
invest wisely and a big part of that is
getting good investing advice the vast
majority of millionaires use an
investment advisor
to teach them and then they make their
own decisions
our team recommends trustworthy vetted
investing pros from all over the country
we call them smart fester pros to get in
touch with the smart investor pro in
your area go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash smart vester and start building
wealth today that's ramsey solutions dot
com
slash smart vester
george campbell is my co-host today alex
is with us in sacramento hi alex welcome
to the ramsey show
hi thanks for
answering sure how can we help um
i have a question about cancer insurance
and
so i know you don't recommend cancer
insurance but i was wondering if that
still applies
in my situation
so i have a genetic mutation
where my chances of getting breast
cancer increased to about 70 percent and
i scheduled the appointment to meet with
my insurance company and i'm about to
cancel it but i want to make sure that
i'm doing the right thing
okay so what is your can what kind of
cancer insurance do you have
um it's cancer insurance offered through
my workplace um basically if i get like
some kind of
service that's related to cancer
like a mammogram then i'll get like a
little
check like a good job for doing that and
then if i do get cancer then
i'll get
a percentage of what i would have gotten
um if i were working
okay so it covers your income if you're
off from work due to cancer
yeah but i have to have a cancer
diagnosis yeah i know i understand that
and uh but mammograms are free with
almost every
health insurance plan out there now
right
yeah yeah okay so
so really this is basically disability
insurance in the event of cancer only
do you have long-term disability
insurance
yes i just signed up so now i do good do
you have an emergency fund
um only over a thousand i'm still on
baby step two okay and how much does
your cancer insurance cost
um
about 30 bucks a month
okay and what does it pay if you get
cancer
70 of your income right
yeah for how many
months i'm not sure
okay be good to know
be good to know how long before it
starts too after a cancer diagnosis
does it start six months after or six
days after
that's important right
okay so here's the thing if you have
three to six months of expenses i would
drop it even in your situation it's a
gimmick is what it is they don't sell
heart attack insurance they just sell
cancer insurance and as many people die
of heart attack as they do cancer
but they just cancer so scary and it's
such a thing and if you've ever had a
loved one and most of us have that have
had cancer then it just you know just
devastates you emotionally and so it's
you're so susceptible to that so i would
keep it for now but i would not keep it
long-term because it is really not a
good product
but for right now you know 30 bucks a
month is covering you because you only
got a thousand dollars but once you have
three to six months of expenses set
aside and long-term disability insurance
in place you've got no need for it
yeah you talk about this in financial
peace university in that insurance
lesson there's so many different types
out there and writers you can add and a
lot of them are just gimmicks and
they're covered through your normal
insurance they're covered through
long-term disability so you really gotta
look at the fine print no pun intended
to figure out what you actually need and
alex i do want you to do just exactly
that george is right because you don't
know what you're getting for your 30
bucks and here's the rule in insurance
if it doesn't cost much
there's a reason
the fact that it's only 30 bucks 360 a
year there's a reason because it doesn't
cover much so it either has a
elimination period meaning it starts
late or it's a short payout it doesn't
pay out for very long
and they know that on average covering a
young woman of your age
that that's where you are so i'd leave
it in place for today but i want to
learn what it actually covers and then i
do want to get your emergency fund in
place the fully funded one and then drop
it at that point just because you in
particular are worried about this
because of this genetic situation
for most people i just drop it
period
just because it really doesn't cover
much when you get down into it it just
doesn't there's not much benefit for the
cost that's what it comes down to
so good question thank you for joining
us eli's in clarksville hey eli welcome
to the ramsay show
you
how can we help
so i'm a sergeant in the army right now
and i'm planning to get out june in uh
june 18th of this coming year
and i have about 60 days of leave before
i do get out
and like the army will still pay me for
like that that time
but i'm not sure exactly
what i want to do when i get out
because like i there's all kinds of
different options and i was just hoping
that you could
i don't know like uh
help me like figure out like how long of
like a window i really have to like
figure out what i need to do eli how old
are you
i'm 22 and i turned 23 in february
awesome well thank you so much for your
service and sacrifice first of all
thank you
so when it comes to what you want to do
you've this this is all you've known is
being in the military right
yes sir so what you got to do is figure
out what do i want to do for the rest of
my life as a 22 23 year old and we've
been talking about you know ken's book
from paycheck to purpose and i want to
gift you that book and i want to also
gift you that get clear assessment
that's going to help walk through
what are you really wired to do because
there's a lot of things you could do
like you're saying i've got a lot of
options is there anything that comes to
mind when you think hey man if i could
get out and do anything here's what i
would love to do
with my life with my work
so i mean i'm a really big fan of like
helping other people out and like
uh doing kind of like a or like doing
like a supervisor type position like so
you want to lead people i thought
i thought a lot about
opening my own business though
but yeah i'm kind of
i don't know i need to learn a whole lot
more about that before i would be able
to move anywhere in that direction
agreed agreed i agree with that you got
time i don't think that's your first
step i think your first step is find
something to move into and begin to find
your way toward something that gives you
joy where you can serve folks and you
can get some sense of soul so george is
exactly right we'll send you the get
clear assessment
take that it's our gift to you to say
thanks for your service and we'll send
you a copy of ken's book from paycheck
to purpose and read every bit of that
and look at every bit of that dig into
it and then dig into ken coleman's
website because you've what you are is
you're on a journey a process here of
self-discovery that's very healthy and
good
people do it at 22 they do it at 32 and
they do it sometimes it's 62. and that's
all okay so just you're finding out what
your next chapter looks like and uh the
good news is even if you pick something
you don't have to do that the rest of
your life you can just take a stab at
something and give it a run and um you
know but but do it with some uh analysis
and with some wisdom and we'll give you
some tools to help you do that
and i think you'll be on your way hey
man and do it go ahead and do it now
don't wait till june start right now
really working hard on where you want to
end up
good hour george well done times thank
you well done james and kelly in the
booth we appreciate you this is the
ramsey show we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts